this video is brought to you by mine
[Music]
hey wisecrack helen here so something
weird is happening to
ostensibly smart public figures lately
public
intellectuals if you will neil degrasse
tyson who built a massive platform to
spread science literacy
has transformed into a weird
well-actually guy
who says very dumb things about
philosophy my concern there is that the
philosopher
believes they're actually asking deep
questions about nature
and to the scientists it's what are you
doing why are you wasting your time
why are you concerning yourself with the
meaning of meaning which i am still
very mad about neil then there's your
elon musk type
who has leveraged his fortune and fame
to become a self-appointed spokesman on
a wide variety of issues but routinely
giving out information that is either
bonkers or just plain deceptive to the
point that even i
a once self-proclaimed elon musk fangirl
can no longer stand
behind him the institutions that publish
public intellectuals aren't doing well
either the new york times can't seem to
go one month without putting out a
massively ridiculed op-ed from brainy
folks like david brooks
and then there's the hundreds or
thousands or jesus i can't even count
the amount of youtube talking heads with
hyper-dedicated followings
good and bad they cover current events
in popular culture while it's too
diverse a group to describe
monolithically
and i won't name any names for fear of
provoking their legions these youtube
public intellectuals might have come
across your feeds for
for instance not understanding basic
human anatomy it'd be easy to think that
our society is getting dumber or are
great thinkers less
rigorous but that doesn't seem like a
fair assessment
there are some truly great intellectuals
out there doing
great work still as chronically online
people who like to learn
we're convinced that there's something
severely messed up about how knowledge
is created and shared in the 21st
century
so what if degrasse tyson's weird
twitter threads are a symptom of a much
larger problem
and what if the biggest threat to good
ideas is not at all what you thought
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on public intellectuals
what happened but first here's a bad
idea letting your personal data float
around the internet forever
this week's sponsor is mine mine is a
really helpful and free to use smart
data assistant
these days it's easy to feel like your
data is out of your hands
but mine helps you discover where it is
and what kind of data is out there the
process is
really simple and quick all you have to
do is go to samemind.com using the link
in the description
and sign in using google microsoft or
yahoo it'll give you a summary of
everything that your email is attached
to you can see how
many companies hold your data and see if
they're storing sensitive stuff
like identity or financial information
when you move over to your footprint
you can see every company that holds
your data and the risk of data breach
there are so many sites i haven't used
for years that are still collecting my
data
which sucks so it's great i can just
send a request to have it removed
take control of who has your information
by looking into mine today
click the link in the description to
check it out for free it is a
strange time for our society
intellectually speaking the amount of
money flowing into foundations both
liberal and conservative to produce new
and original research
is unprecedented authors are paid tens
of thousands of dollars to speak to
private and public groups of curious
minds there are whole conferences
dedicated to exploring new and
disruptive ideas
and places like youtube have reduced the
traditional media stranglehold
on the dissemination of ideas if there's
a marketplace of ideas where information
good and bad gets to duke it out for
supremacy
one might think this is a kind of golden
age but not many
do so what's going on to figure that out
let's talk about what scholar daniel
dresner calls
the ideas industry a vast ecosystem of
thought production
that stands in contrast to the
intellectual landscape of decades past
for dresner a public intellectual is a
person who comments on a variety of
ideas
they know enough about many things to be
able to point out intellectual
charlatans
they expose accepted wisdom when it
doesn't stand up to scrutiny
and for this a public intellectual is
crucial to democratic discourse
they span the ideological spectrum
people like william f buckley
bertrand russell or james baldwin the
french love them
and people like jean-paul sartre simone
de beauvoir and michel fuco were
superstars in the bistro line streets of
their native country
they went on tv and radio and criticized
their government's foreign policy
they would debate about race and racism
and so on public intellectuals still
exist
but for everyone you can name there's
probably a dozen pseudo-intellectuals
who come to mind much more easily what
dresner calls
thought leaders a horrific invention of
the ideas industry
you probably know the type someone with
a big idea an idea that will
revolutionize everything if a public
intellectual curmudgeonly points out
what's wrong with everyone else's
worldview
a thought leader is an evangelist for
their own public intellectuals tread
carefully and weigh evidence
thought leaders have a product to sell
and sometimes
public intellectuals are seduced into
becoming thought leaders themselves
enter amy cuddy cutty is a social
psychologist who spent the first few
years of her career doing the normal
academic thing
researching publishing thinking then in
2010
she published a paper suggesting that
one's posture could have effects
not only on their psyche but their
biochemistry
by doing a power pose say a person could
not only experience
feelings of power but raise their
testosterone and reduce the levels of
cortisol the stress chemical
in their blood intimidated before your
big sales meeting do a power pose
gotta ace and exam power pose stuck on
dark souls
stand up put your legs in a wide stance
and pick that controller back
up my guy it's not just defeating demons
though
cuddy and her fellow researchers
suggested this simple hack might be of
particular use to those who feel
chronically powerless whether it's
because you're the grunt in an
organization
or because you belong to a social group
that has been in scientific terms
screwed by society two years later cuddy
would go on to give a ted talk about the
topic that will become the platform's
second most popular with over 40 million
views
the implication of course is that if
you're powerless in society
the power pose can help you climb to the
top of the social hierarchy thus
combating inequality
and i realized that she had not just
faked it till she made it
she had actually faked it till she
became it also
ted talk tickets are between five and
ten thousand dollars
i don't make the rules while cuddy is no
doubt an academic her ted success had
launched her into the role of a thought
leader as author anand garadartas writes
in his book
winners take all her academic work now
was competing with a budding speaking
career
and a self-help book she was named a
game changer by time magazine in 2012.
she had a product and that product was
the power pose
of course as an academic she was
interested in other kinds of research
that
in theory she would also like to expose
to a wide audience but
instead of boosting her other work her
ted fame did the opposite as garrett
artist notes
despite cuddy's rising fame she found
herself in a dilemma
she was an academic interested in
studying the complexities of prejudice
and sexism
and yet her ted talk had drowned out
every other thing she had ever said
and now she was fielding lucrative
invitation after invitation to offer her
ideas
the lack of interest in her other work
was not exactly a coincidence either
cudi had made a splash at the idea
circuit defined by events like ted
south by southwest or the aspen ideas
festivals
and made it to the big leagues of the
ideas industry
at this point authors like drezner and
girod artists note people like cudi
basically become paid intellectuals for
the kinds of people who can dish out 10
grand to attend a ted talk in the first
place
once you've impressed your affluent
audience you get to give more talks to
the executives or staff at goldman sachs
facebook or google
and there is a reason these
organizations weren't interested in
cuddy's other research
their bottom line the audiences cudi was
speaking to
and being paid lucratively by wanted to
hear only certain kinds of messages
ones that were disruptive just not
disruptive to their own place in the
world
the googles facebooks and goldman sachs
of the world are interested in
hiring someone like cuddy so long as her
message is a win-win
the power pose is a safe solution to say
workplace sexism
no complex changes to company culture
have to occur and
most importantly nobody has to lose any
money what especially moved such
audiences
eurodartus writes was the rendering of
social problems
as unintimidating bite-sized digestible
now cuddy isn't some lone wolf she
exists amidst a ton of names you
probably recognize
who write books that end up in airports
give talks at big conferences
and get referenced by important people
doing important things
and their lifeblood comes from the
corporate benefactors that like their
win-win mentality and this
isn't without consequence harvard
business school professor gotham mukunda
argues that wall street clings to power
but promoting ideas that promote the
rightness of that power
they reward those that agree with them
and punish those who don't
as often sinclair said it is difficult
to get a man to
understand something but his salary
depends on not understanding it
the result can be an entire society
twisted to serve the interest
of its most powerful group we can also
compare it to someone like
cheryl sandberg who wanted to offer a
win-win solution to sexism by
encouraging women to
lean in of course serious scholars cudi
included
understand that these problems are far
too complicated to have any quick fixes
but complexity is not what the ideas
industry is interested in
cuddy isn't getting into the door at the
coca-cola center for civil and human
rights
which is a real thing by asking hard
questions about why union leaders in
their south american bottling plants
have repeatedly disappeared but she
might get a fat check for explaining to
their head of progress how workers can
personally grow
by feeling more confident cudi is an
interesting example precisely because
she seems acutely aware of these
problems becoming a fascinating subject
for gerhardis book to document
but cuddy's introspection is not
universally present in the many thought
leaders speaking to anyone who can cut a
50 grand check
and make no mistake that's really how
much some of them get paid
historian niall ferguson reportedly
received 50 to 75 000
per speech malcolm gladwell also
reportedly receives over 50 000
per speech and if you were mad that
hillary clinton was getting 200 grand to
speak to a bunch of wall street execs
it's common practice
for tons of politicians including every
ex-president like george w bush and bill
clinton
with the rare exception of jimmy carter
it's not that every idea any of these
people ever had is bad
while we might say hey get paid who
cares
it creates a perverse incentive for
intellectuals and ex-politicians to not
rock the boat too hard
unless they want to miss out on hundreds
of thousands of dollars this incentive
also creates an echo chamber of ideas
paid for and consumed by
the people running the world as
gyrodardus writes the money can liberate
the top
thought leaders from the institutions
and colleagues that might otherwise
provide some kind of intellectual check
on them
while sometimes turning their ideas into
advertisements
rather than self-contained work a
consequence of an academic receiving
these massive payouts like ferguson
is that he doesn't have to please his
editors he sure as hell doesn't have to
please scholars he has to please
corporations and high net worth
individuals what's more cuddy's power
pose research
wasn't very good as is good science
someone tried to replicate her findings
they failed her co-author even disowned
the study
the point is this is not the kind of
thing the ideas industry cares about
they want sound bites that make
executives feel good
not objective science what we're left
with is a whole universe of incredibly
intelligent people who have no incentive
to criticize the status quo
they're turned from critics of
everything like a public intellectual
to thought leaders who are evangelists
of not too disruptive ideas for silicon
valley
as dresner writes ted talks are designed
for thought leaders to appeal to
plutocrats
at less than 20 minutes they are
mercifully short
a perfect format for potential patrons
the working rich are busy people
operating on a compressed schedule you
have certainly encountered many trendy
ideas secreted by the ideas industry and
its corporate benefactors
the very real and cool practice of
mindfulness meditation has been stripped
of anything that might mess with worker
productivity as we discussed in our
episode on the topic
malcolm gladwell's idea of ten thousand
hours has come under scrutiny for just
being outright wrong
then there's something like the 4-hour
work week which promises your regular
economic output
if you only work 4 hours by underpaying
overseas personal assistance
of course ted talks and speaking gigs
aren't writing neil degrasse tyson's bad
takes on philosophy
or a legion of rage filled youtube's
creeds but the public sphere of ideas
is being injected by a steady stream of
ted heads leading to shallow takes that
make easy targets for long invectives
we're left debating with a torrent of
trash instead of quality ideas and the
pressures felt by cudi
is the same pressure being exerted on
smart people looking to be heard
but we'll get there it also gives people
incentive once they've ascended to
prominence
to close themselves off from criticism
thomas friedman has stated he can
basically write whatever he wants
i'm in this scary and enviable position
he said
i can go to my publisher and say i want
to write a book
here's the check don't you want to know
what it's about but the public speaking
circuit
isn't even the scariest source of our
pipeline of garbage ideas
for that we have to turn to the think
tank
american think tanks started sprouting
up in the early 1900s as people started
wondering if the governor's drinking
buddy was
maybe less equipped to deal with trade
policy than some kind of expert
these think tanks claim to be
non-partisan although they certainly had
their own ideologies
some of them are still around today like
the council on foreign relations which
publishes foreign affairs and the
brookings institute whose goal is to
analyze public policy issues at the
national level
as dresner writes they were there to
assist government bureaucrats to work in
conjunction with them
at the same time they were bankrolled by
the very wealthy the carnegies and the
rockefellers of the world
while think tanks were never some kind
of perfect organization
events in the last few decades have
cemented their position
as a way for people with a lot of money
to launder ideas to politicians and the
public at large
while the new model might be exemplified
by the conservative heritage foundation
under former senator jim demint it has
since gained popularity for liberal and
progressive think tanks as well
deminch was very good at fundraising but
most notably
he had his staff review all heritage
papers to ensure that they conformed to
the official policy of the think tank
it was the success of heritage that
would convince people like the
billionaires herbert and marion sandler
to cut a
20 million dollar check to john podesta
to create the liberal
center for american progress like their
conservative counterparts
the center for american progress is
about promoting a certain world view
not creating rigorous scholarship or
thought as the head of the competitive
enterprise institute told an interviewer
groups like ours how do we earn
credibility we have a very strong point
of view
and we've never deviated from that point
of view as they grappled with incredibly
complex issues like poverty alleviation
and fiscal policy it wasn't the facts
driving their conclusion
it was their pre-existing beliefs as
author david callahan summarizes
the think tank was invented in the 20th
century to offer objective analysis
of complex issues now though think tanks
often operate as the motherships of
ideological movements
on both the left and the right these
think tanks aren't just thinking in a
bubble
they're a hugely influential part of
american politics
for instance changes to federal welfare
were made in 1996
after millions of dollars were poured
into research arguing that much social
spending just made poverty worse
and as callaghan notes the foreign
policy vision behind the iraq war
was partly made by a think tank the
project for the new american century
in another example large sums of money
were given by the united arab emirates
to centrist think tanks like the middle
east institute
if think tanks were once a way to
provide independent expertise to
governments
they have become a way for a donor even
a foreign government
to influence policymakers you've
probably even been exposed to paid for
ideas as you watch tv youtube or scroll
through facebook for instance
public opposition to an iran nuclear
deal in 2015
soared after a huge influx of
advertising dollars by interest groups
and think tanks
if disruptors and thought leaders seem
so appealing it might be because many
have intuited a kind of intellectual
bankruptcy
everywhere in the world lately it seems
like everyone is quick to throw their
own facts and figures
that tell exactly their side of the
story it can lead to a kind of factual
nihilism
my facts are objective and yours are
created by some shill funded by george
soros
and it's entirely likely that the
existence of think tanks fuels this
problem
not that we'd all be able to get on the
same page otherwise but think tanks have
dressed up
ideological propaganda as objective
studies to return to our upton sinclair
quote it is difficult to get a man to
understand something
when his salary depends on not
understanding it
this is the marketplace of ideas that
one looking to become a public
intellectual
must grapple with unless they're willing
to bend their views they're unlikely to
survive at a think tank
they might get a job at a university
however the publisher perish model
encourages them to not engage with the
public and instead double down on
writing to an audience of a few dozen
specialists
and then there's the internet amidst
think tanks ted heads and
countless paid for media there exist
podcast hosts
political commentators twitch streamers
and vloggers
eager to dispense wisdom but these
thinkers
aren't just thinking into a vacuum
they're developing intellectual brands
it's the brands of people like amy cuddy
that allow them to keep
raking in speaking deals or the brands
of columnists like paul krugman or barry
weiss which rack up book deals
while in a sense this is nothing new
there are some unique challenges faced
by today's would-be intellectuals
there's a growing sense that
intellectuals of all stripes are
producing knowledge cynically
with a certain agenda in mind and if
you're looking for the stuff that comes
out of policy institutes
think tanks and the speaking circuit
you're not wrong general distrust toward
mainstream ideas along with a declining
faith in government institutions
seems to have drawn many of us to
outside commentators to rogue public
intellectuals
when everything is broken it makes
perfect sense to look for an outside
perspective
elon musk as a thinker is appealing
precisely because america's
infrastructure is crumbling
maybe you love how he's trying to
revolutionize transportation
or maybe you think he's deeply misguided
but most can probably agree that the
problems he's addressing
are problems to begin with bill gates
both the public
intellectual and the person funneling
money into intellectual endeavors that
fit his worldview
can step up to much praise and many
accolades precisely because of our
waning public health infrastructure
but what's going on with neil if the
marketplace of ideas
loves one thing it's competition and if
you're looking to craft an intellectual
brand
you've gotta out compete the rest as
david carr wrote in 2012
the now ancient rounds to credibility at
small magazines and newspapers
toiling and menial jobs while learning
the business have been
wiped out replaced by an algorithm of
social media heat
and blog traction social media
especially twitter and facebook have
made it possible to very easily quantify
the currency an idea has
via engagement in shares if i'm getting
retweeted more
i'm being heard more and i'm winning in
the ideas industry
on my way to book deals new york times
columns and lucrative speaking gigs
and while this might be the pinnacle of
the marketplace of ideas
it's also exposed a problem with that
market markets are great at finding the
equilibrium of supply and demand it can
really help me decide how to price my 80
potatoes so i can sell them all but this
mathematical equation
doesn't solve for truth it does however
find out exactly how many people want to
retweet neil degrasse tyson complaining
that a marriage story
should be called a divorce story the
free market of ideas
often overvalue name brand intellectuals
who have long given up on being
insightful
dresner explores how many intellectuals
have taken to hiring a staff
who go as far as to outsource the
writing or research of their work
fareed zakaria for instance has a staff
of eight people to run his show and
write his columns neil ferguson has a
full-time researcher and undergraduates
assisting him
and in the end it can lead to a serious
decline in quality
most people who are good at being
intellectuals are lousy at managing
subordinates dresner argues
fittingly in 2012 zecario was accused of
plagiarism after cutting and pasting
from a new yorker essay
in 2015 there were dozens of such
accusations against him
that had piled up it shouldn't be
surprising that the majority of dialogue
happening on youtube or twitter
is the slam dunk nobody is going around
looking for robust ideologies to
critique
they're looking for rubes who makes
seemingly bizarre claims about feral
hogs
or elon musk making bad predictions
about kova deaths
youtube commentators are looking for the
dumbest most outrageous thing to make a
video about to soak up easy views
we demand it and they supply it it also
drives a market of
well actually material by people like
neil degrasse tyson who can incessantly
complain that we're
all using the word awesome wrong and on
the other hand there's people like
michael who can't wait to pithily leave
a response about how dumb his twitter
takes are
at the same time as sociologist will
davies writes
truth has become a kind of war zone that
is not very good
at finding the truth truth he argues
comes from dialogue and consensus
not from a weird fetishization of
conflict and debate
when scientists for instance are trying
to create a coveted vaccine the guy
shouting debate
me about his theory of microscopic
minions is not the missing piece of the
scientific puzzle
there are certainly public intellectuals
still out there and like all things
there are good ones and bad ones
but the actually terrifying thing is how
hard it is to navigate where good
information
is even as a chronically online
millennial i can't help but question
every single item that comes across my
news feed
is it some thought leader shrieking into
the void is it some paid for
think tank study but what do you think
has the rise of the thought leader
ruined intellectual discourse
is twitter making any search for
objective truth impossible
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our patrons for all your support
hit that subscribe button like you're
retweeting degrass tyson's bad hot take
and as always peace
[Music]